each language has its own sound and
structure and feels a certain way
Italian is musical while German is
harsher and the same person fluent in
both can seem like they have two
distinct personalities but can language
really influence who we
[Music]
are linguistic relativity Theory
suggests that the languages we pick up
and use influence how we see the world
the perception of our surroundings our
sense of time our memories our behavior
and even our sense of
self first there's our perception each
language has different words that
describe the things around us and these
differences change the way we perceive
these things for example an Italian
might see objects as male or female
while an English speaker won't a
phenomenon that extends to the
perception of
space the cook Tor an Aboriginal tribe
does not use left or right in their
language instead they rely on cardinal
directions north east south and west
they might say pass me the salt on the
southwest of the pepper it's probably no
coincidence that they have Supernatural
navigational
skills there is the sense of time
because languages are written in
different directions people who write
left to right will perceive the secret
qu of events accordingly speakers of
Arabic and Hebrew might do so the other
way
around in the Emil language in Papa
Guinea there are three forms of past
tense today's past tense yesterday's and
remote past tense to use the correct
verb speakers need to pay close
attention to when something has happened
and hence May perceive the past in
Greater
detail language also affects our memory
memories in English if a child breaks a
vase accidentally we may say he broke
the vase putting the responsibility on
the kid in Spanish people would say elh
Haron serpio or the vas broke giving
more credit to the environment a small
difference with big
consequences studies show that speakers
of languages like Spanish that tend to
consider these kind of events accidental
are less likely to recall the people
involved in languages that emphasize an
intention the actors are remembered more
clearly and if things end up in court
the accused is more likely to be found
guilty if the language used during the
trial is active like
English then there is our Behavior
languages are often associated with
culture and with the context in which it
was learned as a result those who speak
various languages access different parts
of
themselves
one study on Spanish English bilinguals
showed that people exhibit different
personality traits when switching their
language when speaking English subjects
were more agreeable but when they
switched to Spanish they were more
neurotic and finally our sense of self
the words we speak also influence how we
feel about ourselves self-affirming
language for example activates brain
areas linked to reward and
self-perception and can increase our
confidence an effect that extends to how
we perceive
pain bilinguals report greater levels of
pain when they speak the language to
which they relate the most the theory if
one language represents a bigger part of
their identity they also perceive the
sensations inside their body with
greater
intensity with about 7,000 languages all
around us nobody knows exactly how they
affect our minds but they certainly
frame our thoughts and influence the way
we look at the
world in Thai for example the word for
heart ji is woven into their language to
describe a variety of human traits
someone friendly is J D literally a good
heart someone that's patient is jien a
cool heart and someone generous is ji
Guang a big
heart as Benjamin Lee w the linguist
behind the theory wrote language is not
merely a reproducing instrument for
voicing ideas but rather is itself the
shaper of ideas the program and guide
for the individual's mental
activity so if you ever learn a new
language remember you're not just
learning new words you're opening your
mind to a new way of seeing and
interacting with the
world what do you think do you speak
more than one language and if so do you
feel like your behavior changes when you
switch between them tell us your
thoughts and experiences in the comments
[Music]
below this video was brought to you by
Wise one.i Wise one is an all-in-one
browser extension that offers a new way
of reading and exploring information
online it consists of five useful
features Focus helps you understand
complex Concepts and words crosscheck
helps you access factual and reliable
sources reporting on the same subject to
get diverse perspectives ask anything
simplifies complex information into
understandable and sourced answers from
the web summarize helps you read more
efficiently without losing information
by providing key takeaways to remember
and explore provides articles and videos
from diverse sources to deepen your
understanding of a
topic wise one is free and available in
different languages and also works on
PDFs all of this makes wise onean an
excellent tool for learning new things
developing your critical thinking and
getting answers to your most complex
questions to install wise one visit
wis. click the add-on Chrome button and
install the extension that's it try it
now Wis onecom
Io if you found this helpful check out
our other videos and subscribe if you
want to support our work join us on